دول العالم تسابق الزمن لاجلاء رعاياها في
السودان في وقت تتواصل فيه المعارك
الداميه بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع لكن
امال السودانيين في انهاء الحرب تتقلص
ويتزع حجم المخاوف من طول امد الحرب
تقديرات محليه ودوليه اعتبرت ان هذه
العمليات دلاله واضحه الى موجه عنف مقبله
وهو ما يراه السودانيون دليلا على غياب
افق الحل السياسي في البلاد واستمرار
النزاع الدائري ليصل امتداده الى الاحياء
السكنيه
رساله المجتمع الدولي واحده وقف الحرب
واسكات المدافع والبدء في الحوار والبحث
عن الحل السياسي لانه لا يوجد حل عسكري
لهذه الحرب وهذا ما نقوم به من خلال اخراج
مواطنين لست مضطرا للشرح ما يحدث هناك
تراه انت تشاهد التلفاز لذلك يجب ان يخرج
مواطنون ومن المستحيل الاستمرار في العمل
كدبلوماسي لذا فان افضل شيء تفعله معهم هو
اخراجهم
اصوات اطلاق الرصاص وداوي الانفجارات يبغى
على دعوات التهدئه ويزيد من تعقيد عمليات
اجلاء الرعايه المحاصرين بين الجانبين
المتحاربين رغم تعهدات دوليه واقليميه
باسكات البنادق والتوصل الى تسويه سياسيه
سلطان العربيه
اشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على
زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات